um
deep reverence that record was
obviously sean's verse was recorded
after nipsey passed
um was that was that nipsy verse
gonna be for sean originally or was it
how did that work out
we was just cooking you know i'm saying
like
the same time we had dead racks in the
middle he pulled up
um we did the first verse and he was
like man pull something else up
start start going through beats pulled
up the deep reverence beat
loaded it up he sat there thought it out
did the verse
and uh again he was like [ __ ] let's go
to some other [ __ ] so we just was
flipping through ideas and
that was one that just was so happening
to me sitting there on one day
being uh sean was just having a real
life conversation about a lot of the
stuff that he talked about in
in deep reverence and um i was like bro
you got to put this [ __ ]
in a song in the song so i pulled up the
nip joint i was like this could be the
perfect [ __ ] for you to just spazz on it
he went in was it hard like because you
know there's the interview clip at the
end where he talks about one to work
with sean
was it how hard was it to get you know
his fam
to clear to clear the verse was it i
mean they showed love for sure black sam
like steve stevo like the whole squad
they just
made sure it was a1 it wasn't you know
too tough i mean me and nip got a grammy
together so it's like that shit's crazy
you know what i'm saying that i'm taking
care of the music for sure
yeah racks in the middle is uh all-time
amazing record wow getting that grammy
bro had to be like a
bittersweet thing you know what i'm
saying winning that but not having it
there to have it with you
nah yeah that [ __ ] was um it was dope
getting the grammy but yeah i mean
a lot of people ask me like what which
one mean more out of like [ __ ] in
paris and racks in the middle it's just
like
you know they both mean a lot but racks
that [ __ ] just was like
unreal bro like just seeing that whole
play all the way through and it actually
play out it's no
it was no industry [ __ ] to making a
record it wasn't no
andr ash [ __ ] like i put the record
together nip was [ __ ] with it he
you know it was his whole thing was like
i don't care who
not [ __ ] with this [ __ ] i'm making
sure it come out like his label was like
fighting him like yo it's another record
by another artist coming out you need to
hold off and whoopty whoop and he was
like man [ __ ] that he was like i went
and banged on them [ __ ] and
make them put it out so it's like for us
to win a grammy and then the other
record not even be mentioned it's like
okay i guess i do know something you
know no it was funny because i remember
when nip put the record out like we
i was talking to him and he was just
like i was like yo so like
was this like on the album and he's like
nah just it just feels like we like it
just felt
like we need to put this out like and
just see what it does because
one of them records definitely man it
was it was just all
time and man and oh god it just was a
line it was supposed to happen
yeah and also a record that really
helped you know obviously rowdy was was
doing his thing but really kind of
helped kick off
roddy's you know commercial looks